thank you
[Music]
all right we got a 17 year old mom in
Jacksonville just doing the mom thing he
was of a mommy 16 year old son you know
damn thing raising a baby you know how
it goes
change your diapies
that's been common for the most of the
world right they I don't think they ever
name who the dad is maybe she doesn't
know but um she got a nine month old
baby boy that just keeps on crying you
know how that is right crying ass [__]
with me here yeah yeah yeah isn't that
the worst baby keeps crying mom can't
get a nap so she's like
it could be tiresome thing you just want
to take a break as a mom what did she do
no
no you're relating
Rolex the Mickey Mouse little baby
bottle she mixes up a little formula
what's in the formula
just your standard mom stuff
so uh you know as moms do they hold
NyQuil put a little extra something to
get the baby snoozing yeah oh no
um Fair life in there for the extra
protein come on baby yeah something like
that yeah oh is it like rum and sleeping
pills it wasn't rum no it wasn't that
crazy it wouldn't come on vodka as a mom
would you put the tequila whiskey
whiskey no hanger Robitussin NyQuil you
ever done that as a mom like no okay uh
all right so uh you know she wants to
get the baby calm enough just so she can
have a little nap so we're clear put
some it's definitely not ever clear guys
come on this is a there's a mother and
her baby Xanax
do moms do that THC no what they did she
shotgun she shotgun the some I think it
depends if it's like Mom what the [__]
does that mean I'm showing you
and then there's 17 year olds and the
mom is down here
I mean yeah she's 17 but I don't know if
that necessarily has anything to do with
this no you're just you're just [__]
I mean you're just [__] doesn't
matter what other titles you have your
brain is still smooth
you think you'd be a pretty good 17 year
old no no no absolutely not really yeah
that's why I waited till my 30s dude
but the sessions yeah So eventually she
gives the formula to the baby what's in
the formula they'll they find out later
she she gives the formula to the baby
baby falls asleep for how long forever
take the little nap now okay you just
sleep mom takes a nap and then the baby
dies
I knew it you son of a [__] no but
listen it turns out she put enough
fentanyl in there to kill 10 grown
adults
whoa
mom's am I right
10 mamas grown adults
can't live with them can't live without
them I didn't know fentanyl puts people
to sleep like ever I know forever no
you're not supposed to do that I mean I
know but like I thought like Julia
you're not supposed to do that okay oh
okay she just she just had a just some
extra fentanyl there like is it a is it
like a depressant or is it a I think
it's just they call it the silent killer
she confused teaspoon with tablespoon
because I do that sometimes when I'm
cooking now so which what actually
happened is that she thought um she
should just this is even dumber okay
when I say it this way she wanted to add
cocaine to the uh oh it doesn't have an
upper in it to bounce it out she she
imagined putting a cocaine pill in the
formula would relax the baby first of
all because it relaxes her but that
cocaine
just ended up to have been laced with
fentanyl like enough to kill 10 grown
adults so she was meant to
50 times over don't people know that you
don't want a crack baby
yes this person is just so uneducated
they're just like give a little quick so
this this mom is
a drug user apparently no I mean she's
definitely under possession of drugs I
don't know if she's a user maybe the
baby's the user you got a cocaine pill
mommy's gonna take that if you're buying
that you're keeping that you're going
out of your way to buy that you're
probably using that you ever take a
cocaine pill no I don't know what the
hell as a crackhead myself I don't even
know what the [__] that is so is it just
a capsule so that you can like yeah it's
almost like a Nespresso machine that's
got the little [__] pods I've never
been Rich enough to do Coke so
wouldn't know yeah
so moms huh moms [__] moms
Geo can you relate
no not can you relate to any pro like
part of that process no because I mean I
had him so I wasn't a single mom I also
didn't uh ever feel the need to send it
to my kid in any way like that
um you guys never felt like just a
little bit like man this [__]
shut the [__] up no shut up motherfit I
mean she definitely didn't for me too
she didn't mean to you know kill her
baby she just really thought with her 17
year old brain yeah you can't be a
[__] and have kids they need to do
some sort of [__] like rationale test
or something but when you guys were 17
though
did it ever occur to you to maybe give
some drugs to a child no I probably
would except I was on drugs the whole
time so I wanted to save it for myself
well well as a drug artist I didn't want
to share never gave in that [__] to kids
I know the [__] harms of it I don't
want to change I don't want to share my
high with other people with customers of
the egg frying on the phone yeah
this is your brain on drugs those
commercials like dude I want my brains
to fry like that dude right but at least
he's got to take it himself oh man too
soon bro
really
you must Miss David because you're
treating me like him I'm sorry what did
David say what would David say he would
call her a [__] but I'm not stupid that
low
you should okay well I'll get you there
I'm gonna get you a cocaine pill I'll
get you there
that is so crazy that
that's why I'm so scared of drugs these
days everything's laced with a lethal
amount of fentanyl [__] everything's
scared and why why fentanyl like why are
they lacing it with it because you can
make you can make every other drug go so
far so fentanyl like one drop will [__]
you up right so like let's say if you
had this much MDMA like ecstasy if I
could put one drop in here this which
would have been a thousand ecstasy pills
is now ten thousand oh so I make so much
more money so you're watering down
yourself yeah let me put a drop of
fentanyl in my Coke in my crack in my
mess in my ecstasy so all of a sudden
I'm like 10xing across the board so
where does this go wrong when like
someone can't measure it correctly or
just how to do it correctly yeah they
don't know math yeah or like they're not
mixing it like let's say if you're
mixing the powder you're not mixing it
evenly you just throw it in there mix it
and you just start stamping pills out
one of the pills might be a hundred
percent fentanyl I see you know you're
just you're not having [__] like
scientists doing this [__] it's just
people making in the garage bathtubs
whatever so it's like that's why it's so
scary to do drugs these days
search a car and then some fentanyl dust
gets in his nose and he goes and then he
dies [__] isn't it crazy to think that
like
maybe she had done this prior with like
other drugs or to the base yeah yeah
um poor baby on the brighter side the
baby's only nine months they probably
didn't know what was going on yeah uh
it's a morbid writer's side but it is
that's what I was thinking too because
then it's like if the kid was like 10
and they're like they know life is
happening and they're like and they're
like mommy there's something wrong I
know processing some [__] they're like
Mommy why do I always like looking at it
okay
why do I always like the lights can you
play the can you do the disco ball again
mom do you think there's anything in
place like do you think America will
ever do something about unfit people
having kids I don't think so dude I
don't think so they tried that's hard
totally unfit people there's also
there's also like 17 year olds that like
successfully raise their children too
you know what I mean it's like really
complex to like statistically then wait
it's a unicorn bro that's what they they
try to do with Planned Parenthood you
know the owner uh the founder of Planned
Parenthood
everyone thought it was like for this
good thing or whatever but she actually
was like oh there's too many like poor
riff raff in this world and we got to
make sure that they don't breed too much
so then they were just like let's get
all these like damn she said that so now
it's also rough right because like
America's known to be the land of the
free and we don't want government
intervention but then who do you expect
to make these calls of like who's fit
and who's unfit to be a parent you know
what I mean
is there an amendment that's just like
freedom to breed
they see it as a human right I think
like like right to pursue happiness and
if having a family is your Pursuit of
Happiness remember that story that we
did it was uh the girlfriend I think it
was in Texas too this girl went to the
hospital for like stomach pain or
something and she had a baby in the
bathroom yeah and then she threw the
baby into the trash she just dunked it
into the trash and then you know she she
had this I think she went to the
hospital with her mom too yeah she went
for stomach and she was also like 17.
and she didn't know she was pregnant she
was secretly pregnant yeah
you know what I don't think in the
article it said her she wins okay but
there could be a chance that she died
she did the Honey Dip put the elbow in
there in the trash so she did one of
these under the leg and then when it
came out but it died in the trash but
she did it under the leg first yeah put
it in the chat under the legs you can't
you can't keep that detailed out yeah
yeah there's lots and then spin again
that was a game breaker yeah the whole
time
whole time you saw a slow-mo of her mom
saying no can you try it with this and
show us something so she I'll be the mom
should she [__] had a baby and then
she goes and then it went to lunch oh
[__] and then she went whoa whoa and
then she went somebody someone's trying
to blog
and then it was like tens ten yeah
right does that help you feel more like
yeah yeah I feel so so happy to be here
right now but in Planned Parenthood was
like yeah so Mom to Mom what would you
say to this uh girl that did this
and let's say she's Mexican just I don't
know yeah so now you feel like are we
talking about the baby dunker or the
fentanyl one fentanyl so I'm like highly
emotional and like I feel for people and
sometimes I swear I can feel what people
are feeling so I don't know if I'd be
pissed with her I think I'd be like
really sad for her for sure you know
what I mean like okay what let like what
life did you live prior to getting
pregnant to even end up in this
situation like 17 and doing this type of
drug I'm like what where did where did
Society fail you or where did your
parents fail you know what I mean to
make those kind of decisions sure dude
like she's not like she she didn't grow
up in a really loving environment to be
there you know she's so nice I'd be like
I'm gonna tie your [__] together
lady
no more kangaroo pouch anymore nope yeah
yeah because I don't think people are
innately evil I would tie her [__]
together can we clip that no but not at
the needle you [__] up
thank you